the evolution of the automobile
faster
sleeker
smarter
okay car commercial guy but you never
show this
music buttons and bluetooth and these
maps mapquest printouts were better than
this
and this isn't just a tech nightmare
it's flat out unsafe worse you end up
using your smartphone
but hope hits the road this week
google's android auto lets you plug your
android smartphone right into the car
bringing up your phone's maps music and
other street legal features
and apple's car play which will be
integrated in cars soon to something
similar for iphone users
starting this week this 2015 hyundai
sonata will be the first car to have
android auto built in
i've been cruising around with the new
software and it really does solve all
those in-car navigation frustrations
but the catch to get all this good stuff
you have to have an android phone and an
android phone running the latest version
of the software
let's go to the statue of liberty
here is statue of liberty national
monument
continue on freedom way for one mile
there are so many things to love about
having google maps riding shotgun not
only do you get the great maps traffic
data and search but the interface is
clean and easy to use
both android auto and apple's carplay
display directions really cleanly and
both use the car's gps which can be more
accurate than your phones
but what carplay doesn't have is google
now google's killer mobile app if my
calendar says i have an appointment at
125 it'll pop up right here and i just
tap and go
and while i'm cruising to that
destination i can listen to spotify or
google music by just controlling it on
the screen or with my voice
play prince little red corvette
playing little red corvette by prince
since much of the android auto
experience is powered by your phone and
it's built-in data you're really just
controlling what's on your phone
call mom
hello
hi mom i'm driving just focus on the
driving man and get off the phone with
me
but what my mom's really gonna hate is
text messaging
here's the message
get back to work poop
respond
i'm driving and working
sending message
but i don't like being distracted by
pop-up messages while driving google
says it will consider letting drivers
turn them off
if you're an android phone owner you're
going to want android auto google's
mobile talents are simply great behind
the wheel iphone owners you may be out
of luck with android auto but you do
have carplay to look forward to i'll be
reviewing that soon
but this is what i know taking the
software design out of the hands of the
car makers and putting it in the hands
of the phone makers really does mean
a smoother ride
you